Joe Biden is very very old and now CBS
News has asked the awkward question to
his Vice President are you ready
so you're 58 now if you win the second
term as you and the president are
running to do he would be 86 at the end
of it The Wall Street Journal had a poll
showing two-thirds of Democrats say Joe
Biden is too old to run again
[Music]
are you prepared to be
commander-in-chief yes I am if necessary
but Joe Biden is going to be fine and
let me tell you something
a little quick on the draw there are
common left not a great look first of
all she's obviously not ready to be
president though the government can
effectively operate without a president
now as it has been under under Biden so
I guess she's as ready as anybody in
that the role of the individual in the
office of president has been diminished
but not a good look for Kamala